to get some food my mother and I would
would would crawl under bombs falling
off because my father remember he can't
hear so he cannot duck when to hear the
bum boom before it explodes so when we
would hear the wh we know to Du and so
my mother and I would go out and dig for
dandelion it was the only Greenery we
had to eat uh for food we had stored
like dried chickpeas and dried beans and
rice so we we could manage with that oil
anything my mother my mother would thrw
the chickpeas overnight and because they
had bugs in them my job was with a pin
to dig the bug out put it on the side
put the chickpea on here and that's how
I killed the time that's how we cooked
our food and you know that that was the
only Greenery we had to eat when we
would go out and dig for dandel allion
to get some water we would crawl under
snipers bullets and we were surrounded
by Islamic snipers and Palestinians who
surrounded our town the hells around our
town